these are the village elders of this  village here where we are just filming  our soccer game oh thank you so much I'm  so put a basic idea where huh here's the  small village of top antenna now just  fill me a little spice of life scene of  kids playing soccer with this little  soccer ball made of rags it was really  just supposed to be a small game the  village kids but everybody and there's  eight full lines of spectators they  seemed extraordinarily into it I imagine  sure that's just their normal easy azzam  well this game proves that soccer moms  are the same all around the world  this is our contribution to the village  kids spank them through playing with us  today you're their ball they're playing  with is just made of rags which is a  pretty great ball to these kids already  soccer stars of the future